Today is a special day.
Today is Mother's Day.
I want to do something special for my mom.
Dad and I wake up early.
Dad and I sneak downstairs.
Quietly, quietly, quietly.
First we make her eggs.
I help crack the eggs in the bowl.
Scramble, scramble, scramble.
Then we make her bacon.
I help lay the bacon in the pan.
Sizzle, sizzle, sizzle.
Then we make her toast.
I help put the bread in the toaster.
Pop, pop, pop.
Then we make her juice.
I help pour the juice in a cup.
Pour, pour, pour.
Then we put it on a tray.
I help decorate the tray with a flower and a card.
Done, done, done.
Dad and I sneak back upstairs to Mom's bed.
I wake up Mom with a hug and a kiss.
Dad hands Mom her breakfast.
We both say.
Happy Mother's Day! We love you!